what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so one of the questions that I've
gotten a lot is like what's the deal
with cable can you like to talk about
cable or something okay so we have like
a tried and true origin video on cable
that you'll find down in the description
but that origin video is really more
geared towards like the hardcore comic
fans as opposed to like the new guys so
this video is gonna be for those
individuals who were just like curious
about who cable is like your average
redditor or somebody like that who's
just like cable like that sounds cool I
wonder who that guy is like this videos
gonna give this videos for you so cable
looks amazing when he's played by Josh
Brolin like the way he's design and how
he looks is awesome but cables whole
story really dates back to like the
1970s and the 1980s ah with the death of
Jean Grey so back when the x-men first
popped up when Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
first made them you had Cyclops you had
Jean Grey you had ice man who had Beast
and you had angel and that was really it
fast forward to the mid 1970s and those
x-men were basically merged with the new
generation of x-men which was like
Wolverine and Nightcrawler and Colossus
and storm and so on and so forth now
what add up happening during this era of
these x-men teams being merged together
is we got something called the Phoenix
saga it was basically this story by a
guy named Chris Claremont that was
designed to just make Jean Grey cool
because she was just the the worst
character ever when Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby were originally writing her she
was like the the weakest character she
always needed help and she was just kind
of really more of like a hassle as
opposed to a help for the team and so at
the end of the Phoenix saga Jean Grey
just like flies into a star everybody
thinks she's dead she like sacrifices
her life and they're like okay Jean Grey
is gone she's out of the picture what
this does is it allowed Marvel to
basically begin segwaying the original
x-men out of the new x-men team so they
basically had Cyclops and morning leave
the original x-men team or I guess leave
the the merged x-men team they had
Iceman walk away they had angel walk
away they had beast the whole nine yards
they all basically just left they were
like okay we can't cope with this
anymore and they went off and they did
their own thing fast forward a few years
and we end up finding out that there is
this villain named Nathaniel Essex also
known as mr. sinister and Nathaniel
Essex had come to the realization that
if Jean Grey and Scott Summers ever had
a kid their kid would just be
ridiculously powerful it would just be a
stupid powerful kid
the problem with this was that Jean Grey
was dead because she was the Phoenix and
so what sinister ended up doing is he
cloned Jean Grey and he created a
character named Madeline prior now when
Jean Grey died and you know so on and so
forth that was Univ her her death
sparked life in Madeline prior but
Madeline didn't have any other powers of
Jean Grey so sinister considered her to
be a failure and just kind of Center out
into the world and said whatever go have
fun so because of this Madeline Pryor
eventually comes across Cyclops
while he's in mourning still trying to
deal with Dean gray but because Madeline
is a clone Cyclops doesn't know the
difference because Madeline has all the
memories of Jean Grey and so to Cyclops
they're basically the same person now of
course this leads to Cyclops learning
the truth but he doesn't care because it
looks just like Jean Grey and she might
as well be the same you know might as
well be Jean is for all the memories and
everything that she has is so but two of
them basically settle down they start a
life together
Madeline pops out a kid named Nathan now
what is Amaro force to the writer Chris
Claremont to bring Jean Grey back and
that's when they brought him the whole
thing about her body being held in
stasis and a cocoon in Jamaica Bay and
the whole idea that like well the
Phoenix wasn't actually Jean it was the
Phoenix force taking on the form of Jean
and yadda yadda yadda anyway stuff that
you've probably read in your Wikipedia
articles and things you've been looking
at online but the fact remains here that
what is up happening as Cyclops bails
out he literally leaves Madeline prior
just abandons his wife and child and
goes back to Jean Grey and then starts a
team called x-factor which is basically
the original x-men with Cyclops Jean
Grey Angel Iceman beast and that's that
I think so what is mhmm finding out that
Sinister's motivation of course was to
basically have Nathan summers born so
that this kid would be powerful enough
to allow senator to achieve any of the
goals that he wanted but we also found
out was that there is a villain named
apocalypse who realized what it was a
sinister was trying to do so apocalypse
sent his own henchmen after Nathan
Summers kidnapped him and then infected
him with a techno-organic virus that's
why cable looks like he's half cyborg
because he's got this virus that's
literally eating his entire cells it's
turning his tissue into metal you know
into cybernetic stuff the problem with
this is that if it overtakes his entire
body it'll kill him and so cable has
telepathy and telekinesis but he
constantly uses his powers to keep that
virus from eating his body alive but
getting back to this
rundown of an origin of sorts I guess is
what this is turned into what is up
happening here is Cyclops realizes that
apocalypse kidnapped his son and so what
he does is he grabs x-factor he grabs
the x-men and he grabs the Inhumans and
he travels over to face off against
apocalypse and get his son back
what is it happening as apocalypse like
wrecks them all it's one of the craziest
thing apocalypse was just like don't
care man like you're all gonna get
totally destroyed but we end up finding
out but the reason why apocalypse
kidnapped Nathan in the first place is
because apocalypse has to jump bodies in
order to keep himself alive and he
wanted to put his spirit inside Nathan
summers because Nathan was gonna be so
powerful enter a chick from the future
we don't need to know her name we don't
need to worry about who she is that'll
just confuse the absolute daylights out
of you what is up happening is this
chick from the future says hey look we
can find a way to try to cure Nathan of
the techno-organic virus and so
ultimately Jean Grey and Scott Summers
have to let Nathan go Nathan goes into
the future something like 2,000 years or
4,000 years or something like that and
he takes up residence with a group
called the clan Toscani
what is up happening here is the clan
Toscani clones cable and they say okay
we have cable who's infected with the
techno-organic virus if we can't cure
him then we'll basically take his soul
or his essence or his mind or whatever
you want to call it we'll take it out of
the infected body and we'll put it in
the clone body but for right now the
clone is just gonna sit there and it's
just gonna be in stasis whatever all
right
this 4,000 years into the future
apocalypse conquered the world and so if
Hawk olaf's learns that nathan summers
has been sent to the future so
apocalypse sends his henchmen over to
Nathan summers again and tries to kidnap
him what is up happening is a clan of
sconnie basically grabbed Nathan summers
they run for their lives
and apocalypse ends up kidnapping the
clone instead apocalypse raises the
clone names a clone strife that's where
that kr character comes from stripe is
stupidly powerful it's nuts how powerful
stripe is but the fact remains here that
cable being you know living 4,000 years
into the future his sole mission his
sole goal is to constantly travel back
into the past and to basically find ways
to kill apocalypse that's it what Marvel
does with his character is they come
along and they say okay so cable is a
guy that we can basically just have him
fix everything because anything that's
happening right now in Marvel Comics has
happened in cables timeline
he's 4,000 years into the future so like
Civil War the original Civil War story
happen and cable talked about that the
Avengers vs. x-men story happened cable
talked about that the Age of Apocalypse
you know the ages strife all these
stories that took place Cable knows
about them all because they all happened
during this time or you know before he
ended up arriving into the future so
nonetheless in terms of his relation to
Deadpool originally the two of them were
enemies what Marvel ended up doing is
they actually launched a story called
cable and Deadpool or Deadpool on cable
whatever you want to call it and what
ended up taking place is they actually
grabbed these two guys and made them
best friends they made them besties and
it's like the funniest thing ever it's
crazy to see these two guys bouncing off
one another and being being silly
Deadpool is absolutely nonsensical and
cable car that tries to keep him in
check
the crazy thing about this is that
cables powers are are kind of nuts to a
degree because there's different forms
of cable there's cable as we're gonna
see in Deadpool - there's strife who
we've already talked about and then
there's a character named Nate gray also
known as x-man Nate gray is from the Age
of Apocalypse he was just genetically
engineered by mr. sinister but Nate
Gray's powers were so extreme his body
couldn't handle it his body actually
burned out because of the powers that he
had he ended up turning into like pure
energy we did a video about him in terms
of all the powers that he has all the
things that he could do it was nuts he
was godlike in terms of the powers that
this kid had he was crazy but Cable had
just has telepathy and telekinesis
he's extremely powerful when he focuses
all of his energy on a particular think
the problem is that if he stops focusing
on keeping the techno-organic virus from
eating him alive then he'll basically
die the virus will totally consumed his
body you'll look like Colossus and then
he'll basically just die and so that's
the reason why his powers are always
kept in bay but what he lacks in
abilities he makes up for in like
hand-to-hand combat and technology one
of the coolest things he has is this
body like a body slide package suite and
what it basically does is it allows him
to body slide any body essentially
teleport and it's cool because an x-men
the animated series they did that he
would be like body slide by two and then
he would just teleport somewhere but he
could also time slide meaning he can
just jump back and forth through time it
will he uses technology in order to pull
that off
but he just bounces back and forth and
time you know whenever it is that he
wants to do it but no cable is is super
cool Cable is really really cool what
you guys are gonna see and Deadpool -
assuming they stick with the cable and
Deadpool you know
and the kind of you know relationship we
saw between the two you're gonna see
what it amounts to like a buddy cop
movie and it's gonna be amazing like
it's gonna be really really cool I'm
really excited for it I think it's gonna
be one of the coolest things that we've
seen from a long time when it comes to
like comic book superhero movies I think
it'll be pretty stellar but anyway
figured I throw this a little bit of a
video out there you know nothing too
crazy nothing too wild we've covered a
lot of cable stuff here on my channel as
origin stories its powers of different
versions of him and so really you know
you can find that stuff down in the
description that should give you
everything you need in order to
understand cable but I just want to make
a quick little video for all the new
folks out there who were just curious
about him in terms of what cables
capable of and what he can do and so on
and so forth but anyway guys if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the robb core do not forget
Wednesday will be Avengers expansion
when cable fights all the Avengers when
he beats the hell out of Captain America
and yeah anyway we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end then I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]